une petite compilation de jeux on
commence tout de suite avec nos peurs
dit non à tout mon oscar c'est super ça
c'est une sorte de copenhague dans les
jeux ou les commandes sont compliquées
on est accroché à une falaise on va
mourir et un [ __ ] de petits poussins
jaunes vient nous picorer doigts et donc
à un sdf contrôler nos doigts c'est
parti mais si abonnez vous [ __ ] ok
faut rester appuyé par exemple ah ah ok
philippe est les doigts ok c'est bon là
j'ai esquivé attrait super compliqué oui
oui tu as la pression de [ __ ] de
poussins pixelisé là tu sais la danse
des doigts c'est la danse des doigts
regardez le détail vive le méthane
lactate a laissé sur le même thème nous
a eu faille où tu as général comme
troisième ça en fait c'est qu'on trouve
tellement bizarre que son cerveau bug on
est très très mal on est traître pétain
a chez moi que nature humaine il met la
pression
taille je pus cannois change de mains
c'est bon
non je suis dans la merde j'ai pu je
peux plus la toupie corée et tout un
petit poucet comme ça ça mange autant
nous avons gardé rarement il prend une
phalange ça y est il est bien vivant je
fais pendant deux semaines oh là là là
on est hyper de venir voir il va rien
pouvoir faire c'est se doit la petit
oiseau va te défoncer sur ce beat nul à
chier ok c'est reparti et l'heure de la
[ __ ] de vengeance mon gars à l'eau aux
eaux qui croit il était il fait que les
mêmes de doigts non monsieur moquer du
petit oiseau c'est hyper chiant parce
qu'en fait tu es comme ça quoi t'es
vraiment commune et en merde non non non
non mais bon là on est bon là elle est
en fait un carnage mon gars c'est la
position mais non mais non c'est quoi ce
droit mais non à baisser le pouce non
compressé sud est un besoin sur hyper
moche
messieurs dames nous sommes maintenant
sur the daily grind c'est parti pour
vivre une journée encore plus nul que
nos journées à nous on a purgé pour se
lever
il a le même biceps que moi on appuie
sur b pour se brosser les dents
c'est passionnant c'est palpitant on
prend la voiture on va au travail
on est arrivé au travail
on travaille c'est passionnant c'est le
meilleur gameplay auxquels j'ai pu jouer
on retourne chez nous en appuyant sur
des le manque de respect on s'endort +50
voilà c'est la fin du jeu c'est ça a
c'est reparti pour une nouvelle journée
pardon je sais que vous voulez en voir
plus sur ce jeu mais on se brosse les
dents
quelle surprise
au nom et tuent des gens en fait et udb
c'est ça la chute du géo [ __ ] ça
valait le coup d'attendre sans l'avis du
temps d'accord on parle là dessus est
tellement de bas c'est nickel enfin
j'aimerais que j'ai refait le jeu ça où
tu peux dézoomer et là on a pu voir qui
tuer des bébés quoi ça dangereux
criminels du coup après je sois justice
on sait combien d'années maintenant à à
leur tour de jeu squeeze c'est la fin du
jeu voilà c'était hyper chiant witcher
hands up in the air on est à l'euro 2016
du 100 m souris c'est à dire d'elle sur
twitter pour ça le but est extrêmement
simple il faut se creuser le plus vite
possible c'est le 100 m scrollant pas se
mentir êtes vous prêt ça attention c'est
parti
mais ça je crois que mon fils allait
faire du vienne disqualifié ok je suis
frais ayem aurélie temps on va tellement
vite bogard on a huit secondes neuf
secondes à temps déjà on est au delà du
record du monde du 100 m real c'est plus
dur semble être une seconde que le sang
est réel moyen qui croit obligé d'y
croire puisque je le dis hein tu prends
pas tu t'es d'habitude 4 allée à
l'escroc je suis qu'à six mètres non
c'est une blague
c'est une blague mais match à temps mais
en un pour mille en moi je voulais faire
un usage pensais que ça durait dix
secondes quoique attendez attendez
attendez attendez moi je pensais qu'on
allait rigoler qu'on avait fait ça pour
s'amuser mais on est là pour gagner
tous les sportifs ont un bandana
sauf que moi nak n'a pas voulu me
sponsoriser la petite bouteille d'eau
pour bien s'hydrater
je sais j'avais plutôt donc j'ai pris et
c'est plus que 0 puis canal 0,60
ok on est sportif haut niveau tarte
c'est parti
je sens massive dans les pêches week a
dit m on a fait un dixième [ __ ] mais
entend courir dans la vraie vie - t'as
l'air moins court et ça devait plus les
abdos des fausses pistes et des jeunes
avec des objectifs pour réussir on va
dire qu'à 50 mètres on a le droit de
boire un coup si on n'est pas mort avant
[ __ ] ou soit je pense racheta fontana
sans lui je n'arriverais pas c'est bon
ok c'est reparti on a fait un tiers ça
remonte toujours le moral ça fait
toujours plaisir et ça brûle à force ça
me brûle la peau sont moqués de nous
vous le regrettez là je vais vous dire
là on va pas blaguer
on dirait un petit pack on dirait tupac
malade il a eu son taux central et les
paris sont lancés
vous mettez maintenant dans les
commentaires combien de temps vous
pensez que je m faire le 100 m crawl
ok attend sur levante sur le monde ça
plus vite sur les côtes sur le tt howey
en plus ça m'excite
[ __ ] je pense à transpirer souvent ça
transpire je me sens mal au final le
plan soit les normands avec vous et
c'est tout bêtement je vois ta
sensibilité de magma molette est ce
qu'on ferait pas sans mettre en deux
secondes
reste la moitié presque à moitié je
m'aperçus objectif de vue jamais ok 50 m
la pause hydratation un petit coup de
sainté on y va c'est parti croyez moi
tous les sportifs de haut niveau font ça
à un moment de leur carrière comment ils
ont plus courage
un petit coup de saintes et ça va
toujours mieux à [ __ ] mais ça fait mal
à force ok plus de 30 m c'est les 30
derniers mettent de l'espoir qu'on va y
arriver on revient on va y arriver
mollard hier je me suis affolé pour air
hockey plus désuète je sais que vous
avez toujours cru en moi que vous avez
là qu'est la vidéo quand je vous ai déjà
indiquer s'ils voulaient bien que vous
êtes fille nue quand je lui ai demandé
vous maintenu pour noyer du courage que
je vous ai dit non et des photos de vous
à poil pour que je puisse me masturbe
n'importe quoi j'ai jamais fait ça à
croquer les deux derniers mètres et de
démettre le ton de tous
non
m
premier mondial on est 100 86 millièmes
440 bah voila j suez j'ai sué gg scrollé
aux mondiaux d'un classement donc on est
bel et bien 100 86 millièmes et le
premier l'a fait combien de secondes
bon bah ce qui est bien c'est qu'il ya
pas tricheurs dans ce classement correct
sur le 100 m crawl et deux autres jeunes
gens sont pas des coûts puisque ce
serait trop c'est trop bien mais ce
n'est pas là mais ça vous a plu
ressources très vite dans une prochaine
n'hésitez pas à faire ça sans tricher
parce que les deux secondes
oui c'est otto habsbourg gnl au maire
savoyarde et portez vous bien chantôme
pis